be outraged so this doesn't go unchecked
especially bannon because there's a
reason why steve bannon and scovino are
trying to skip this
okay
charlie kirk i want to play a video by
him let's see
charlie kirk is [ __ ] idiot
he's such a [ __ ] fool
what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
projecting just complete projection in
this [ __ ] video
what a [ __ ] rube
he's such a dirtbag let's listen to this
these comments from chuck schumer are
important because i want every
republican
out there
to realize that when the democrats are
with he wants every republican
that's a funny word now right
remember how they used to make liberal a
bad word
and they would say you know they use
phrase like libtard i use libtard all
the time
because i want to disarm that word from
them because liberal is not a bad word
progressive is not a bad word it's not
democrat is not a bad word republican on
the other hand
a trump supporter maga that's all
[ __ ] your fascists you're [ __ ]
nazis
so they're calling on all the nazis
charlie kirk is charlie i i'm a nazi
kirk winning they are rubbing it in our
face and some democrat senators some
republican senators are now coming up
and they are stunned
how dare he do this
you think we're still living in the same
country don't you
senators from south dakota
senator portman you think we're still
living in the 1980s where the democrats
actually want
what's best for america
the democrats want to destroy the
country we know this
this is not new stuff
it's not profound thinking
they want to see america completely
obliterated the constitution shredded
and remade in their own
san francisco brooklyn
you [ __ ] idiots that's what you
[ __ ] are trying to do right now
you're trying to commit even a soft coup
as we speak
as we speak just by you making this
video is trying to rally the troops to
have a [ __ ] coup
to overthrow the constitution of the
united states because you didn't win and
you people are [ __ ] losers you're
[ __ ] losers every last [ __ ] one of
you are [ __ ] losers malibu manhattan
image
malibu manhattan there is no cultural
identity this is funny like he's like ah
no [ __ ] no [ __ ] republicans live
in malibu or manhattan you are so stupid
where you live in sexual anarchy
sexual anarchy
what does that mean like there's no
governing body that tells you you can or
can't have sex like that's the whole i
in that liberty isn't that freedom in it
you're right my body my choice mr my
body my choice charlie kirk
i mean
of course you should have a sexual
anarchy you should be able to [ __ ]
whoever you want to [ __ ] however you
want to [ __ ] them right it's my body my
choice
for private property is a thing of the
past
private property's a thing of the past
cause
you know us libtards we don't want home
ownership we don't want title vehicles
personal property you you you stupid
[ __ ] idiots where the [ __ ] do you get
this [ __ ] where in the actual [ __ ] do
you hear this garbage at in your
ivermectin institute facebook group get
the [ __ ] out of here charlie kirk you
are such a [ __ ] rude
why does anyone listen to this look at
him he looks like he just woke up he
can't do his [ __ ] hair i comb my
[ __ ] hair when i come on here and do
my [ __ ] stream it might just be for
mad dog but i still comb my [ __ ] hair
at least i comb my [ __ ] hair and take
a goddamn shower before i come on a live
stream jesus [ __ ] christ
charlie kirk get the [ __ ] out of here
you goddamn fascist what a piece of [ __ ]
let's see what else do we have today
what other news i mean there is some
more news but
let's see oh here's the sexual anarchy
it's trending at number nine
okay we gotta go in here now let me talk
about i gotta go in here uh
there you go there you go
sexual anarchy the absence of government
and absolute freedom of individuals
regardless of political idea i'd have to
agree with charlie kirk on this one i
absolutely want sexual anarchy why why
wouldn't an anti-government anti-big
government
anti-bureaucrat politician the
government can't tell me what to do why
wouldn't they want anarchy as far as
their sexuality that's because they
don't really believe in any of this [ __ ]
they're fascist they don't they don't
believe this [ __ ]
you got it they don't believe this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it's all [ __ ] horse [ __ ] they don't
believe in big government [ __ ] and all
that they want to control women's bodies
they want to tell they are so [ __ ]
frightened that they're [ __ ]
homosexual that they want to tell
lesbians gays bisexuals trans people
they want to tell those people how and
how they have to live their lives and
who they can and can't have sex with
that's why they're terrified they're
terrified they're [ __ ] afraid they're
fragile white pieces of [ __ ]
it's all white fragility
all of it
all of it i've seen it i've grown up i
grew up around it
i got it in my family they're absolutely
[ __ ] terrified
and charlie kirk is a prime example of
why they're terrified terrified of what
terrified a liberty get the [ __ ] out of
here
sexual anarchy shut the [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] dumb how the [ __ ] does this
guy have an audience this guy gets well
why don't you you people don't watch me
but you watch that [ __ ] [ __ ] that son of
a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that son of a [ __ ]
i guess my jealousy is showing through
there maybe i could get charlie kirk's
audience to come watch me what do you
guys think you guys think charlie kirk's
audience would like what i have to say
i actually let's let's look at the
charlie kirk audience here because um
i posted a video here uh from february
is from february and of course i get a
lot of heat in the comments
from these folks